do you think the wire you think movies
like transporting do you think they're
ultimately destruct because okay
yes they celebrate murder right the
godfather a little bit
yeah but
another one i mean it's like these
racist ass [ __ ]
and they also are killing people but yet
they say we don't do drugs what kind of
[ __ ] is that yeah i mean people who are
doing drugs psilocybin or whatever
the thing is we're trying to be better
people and trying to make our society
better and you're killing people and you
are
denigrating
people for using are you [ __ ] kidding
me and we let them get away with that as
a society do you see those movies i
apologize if i'm not sufficiently
informed do you see them as denigrating
drugs
of course i mean the godfather
yes that's right that's a good example
and the godfather the sopranos is all
about that i mean christopher is using
heroin in the sopranos
and
they have an intervention at that one in
one one season and and they are
they are denigrating him it's are you
kidding me you just cut somebody's head
off yeah but they're to be fair they
were denigrating i think all drugs
and then they're drinking alcohol in the
butter bean yeah yeah
first of all they're killing people yeah
they don't have any space
none to denigrate somebody who's just
trying to
alter their consciousness are you
kidding me and not bothering anyone else
but you know there's a lot of other mob
movies that you know scarface celebrates
the murder and the drugs equally
so i i mean it it doesn't
it celebrates all of the
just uh not just drugs or so on it's
those movies
you know i loved all those movies i'm
from miami i loved scarface i even liked
the sopranos that i started looking at
that [ __ ] with a critical eye and see
what it's doing yeah um
but scarface is dependent upon the
american viewer
having a certain view of people who deal
in drugs and that view is that these
people are animals basically and in the
end uh the animal kills himself with too
much cocaine and he was high and that's
what they show and so it's like
what the [ __ ]
so it's leveraging is playing into
not the better angels of our nature
the question don't take away these great
movies for me but it's true you have to
think about them critically in the
continent wait wait wait wait wait wait
i like these movies it's not a matter of
taking away it's a matter of making the
writers
uh be more honest to the reality that's
that's it that's true that's really true
and the the writers the people the
culture all of it i mean they write
these things you you know i just think
about some some hip-hop artists they say
like this is real this is my experience
and so forth
and that's how these movie writers they
write this [ __ ] and then say well
this is real um
anyway i i i get so upset talking about
it because i know the harm is doing and
i know those kind of movies are the
reason that we have this war on drugs um
and all of these people are going to
jail because of those kind of movies
you